let's just bring you some breaking news  that's just coming in we can just show  you some latest pictures from the scene  at manchester crown court and in the  last few minutes we have just seen alex  ferguson arriving  at manchester crown court he's of course  a former manchester united manager he is  arriving as a character witness for the  defense of course this is at the trial  of ex-footballer ryan giggs who's on  trial for controlling and coercive  behavior and also a number of assault  charges against his ex-girlfriend kate  gravel so that is the latest scenes then  coming in from manchester crown court  former manchester united manager alex  ferguson arriving at the court as a  character witness for the defense at the  ryan giggs case